hey I have uh what I would call a giga
cringe moment to play for you this isn't
like a big thing but it's just a
complete and total backfire California
gubernatorial Republican nominee Brian
Dahl tried to make a Biden dementia joke
during his debate over the weekend with
California Democratic governor Gavin
Newsom now it's not like Gavin Newsom
needs any help as I've said before
Newsome is excellent in talking about
the insanity of the American right but
also indirect conversations with right
Wingers
I dare you I double dare you to watch
this clip without cringing look at what
happens when Brian Dahl tries to do a
Biden dementia joke and it just Falls
humiliatingly flat did Joe Biden
legitimately win the 2022 election
against Donald Trump yeah actually he
did win the election but the big
question is he does he know that that's
that's what I wonder sometimes but I
want to talk about he being who
Joe Biden
what do you mean by that well I I yes I
agree that he won the election but I
wonder sometimes if he actually realizes
that he's president of the United States
of course he recognize these and that's
right you're insulting the president
United States of course he understands
he's pregnant
God what a loser
um
silence
silence one of the most awkward silences
of the entire debate season there
I've seen that five times now and I
still get uncomfortable from how awkward
and how flat it falls it is not looking
good in case you were wondering for
Brian Dahl in California uh the latest
polling right now has it at
um Newsome plus 23 23 and that is
expected to be an absolutely incredible
drubbing